you've taken the first step towards
gaining control of your life
and hugs not thugs we rehabilitate
ex-gang members
we offer free legal counseling solar
panel installation classes i even got
dental insurance
and your teeth still look pretty [ __ ]
up though
yeah but guess what they used to be even
more [ __ ] up
my cousin spent the last eight years in
prison sorry i'm late i'm just trying to
help him but that bull won't listen to
me why does your body still look 19 but
your face looks 56 food
no offense my boy but you come off like
a punk ass [ __ ] do you mind moving your
car bad timing
i think i got room
studies show that the life expectancy of
a gangster 24 years old but the life
expectancy of a punk-ass [ __ ]
76 years old i'll just go around
[Music]
thanks fellas
people love buying cupcakes from ex-gang
members boy oh boy seashore some yummy
cupcakes [ __ ] do you want me to relapse
you buy a cupcake
thank you red velvet is an amazing
choice
wanna help us go fight some fools at the
park i can't though i sound like nerd's
been acting up where's the problem my l4
mount five dog damn mine's l5 and s1
come on y'all stay focused
me and maggie just got back together
again who knows how long we're gonna be
together this time
[Music]
i'd rather die than let you fools walk
all over me so just shoot me please
i'ma film this
i don't even have guns
[Music]